boy we have a lot to cover tonight
breaking right now with just hours to go
until the shift show moves to the
Judiciary Committee of course the
psychotic Trump hating impeachment
hearing rage which it's really not and
I'll explain in a minute House Democrats
they have finally released a document
outlining their allegations against the
president the so-called Trump Ukraine
impeachment inquiry report it's really
just the cool report nothing but an
insane convoluted 14,000 word diatribe
concocted by their fearless compromised
corrupt coward congenital liar that
would be Adam Schiff their leader report
is chock full of nothing but conspiracy
theories left-wing opinions conjecture
hearsay witnesses complaints about
Donald Trump's foreign policy by people
that think they're more important than a
duly elected president and a whole lot
of outright lies and yeah two quotes
from George Washington and Alexander
Hamilton they're even dragging them
through the mud this is not a serious
document in fact the only clear piece of
relevant real hard evidence is the
testimony from there only one direct
witness that guy right there ambassador
Gordon sunlen according to the report
quote I'm reading on September 9th
sunlen claimed that the president
answered an open question about what he
wanted from Ukraine with an immediate
denial
I want nothing no quid pro quo that's
the only person under the Federal Rules
of Evidence not to hearsay witnesses not
the opinion witnesses that's the only
guy that could be a real witness in a
real court of law the others
inadmissible and meanwhile the Ukrainian
president Solinsky again this weekend a
short everybody never felt any pressure
no quid pro quo basically said what's
wrong with you people
anyway you're not likely going to hear
this on fake news CNN or yes area 51
Roswell Rachel Maddow is conspiracy
channel M s DNC but over the weekend
during an interview with Time magazine
yes the Linsky actually said the
no quid pro quo look I never talked to
the president from the position of a
quid pro quo and keep in mind president
Trump invited szalinski to the White
House on three separate occasions with
zero stipulations before the ninth yeah
problematic for them USA to Ukraine was
paid out in full and when did they make
the announcement that they were doing
the things that Trump was demanding they
never did and to top it all off that aid
was never discussed in multiple phone
calls between szalinski and Trump aid
never talked about again no one no one
ever testified that Donald Trump ordered
them to withhold aid in exchange for any
political failure favored that would
only be quid and pro and quo and Joe
with this on hunter zero experience
hunter paid millions you're not getting
the billion dollars and let's not lose
sight of something very important the
congenital Liars rambling report was
released just hours before the first
official proceeding there's no time to
mount any legal defense President Trump
isn't even in the country and they knew
that too
and that's not all the congenital liar
the compromised Adam Schiff who
conducted the investigation wrote the
report he is a known repeated congenital
liar
he lied repeatedly about Trump Russia
collusion we have all the evidence for
investigations no evidence he lied about
the president's phone plan to make it up
with President szalinski in Ukraine in
fact he made up an entire fake
transcript and the congenital liar
even lied about his contact with the non
whistleblower or whistleblower hearsay
whistleblower and despite previous
denials on national TV his office was
communicating with the fake
whistleblower from the very beginning
goes oh oh I've forgot to tell you that
and now look at this breaking tonight
according to a major report from
investigative reporter Carrie Pinkett
Washington Examiner Schiff actually
hired a former national security aide
who worked with the named non
whistleblower Ukrainian whistleblower
only one day after the president's phone
call with Ukraine according to the
report quote the pair had a close quote
bro
like relationship while working at the
NSC together so not only was the
congenital Liars office in communication
with the non whistleblower hearsay
whistleblower but they even hired the
fake whistleblower non whistleblowers
work bro right the day after the call in
question I'm not sure this is all one
big coincidence for you and today
President Trump had a few choice words
for the compromised corrupt congenital
liar Adam Schiff let's take a look I
think that objectives a deranged human
being I think he grew up with a complex
a lots of reasons that are obvious I
think he's a very sick man
and he lies Adam Schiff made up my
conversation with the president of
Ukraine this guy he said he made up the
conversation he live if he didn't do
that in the halls of Congress he'd be
thrown into jail but he did it in the
halls of Congress and he's given
immunity this is a sick person he's a
liar the deranged human being has now
submitted his steaming pile of findings
to the Judiciary Committee oh yeah then
we got no nothing Nadler he's going to
attempt to rush the impeachment sham
across the finish line and get it done
before Christmas now like it or not
Nana's planning on well jamming
impeachment down all of our throats you
don't care about the country they've
done nothing for us for three years
except hate on Donald Trump investigate
Donald Trump tell us how bad Donald
Trump is Trump Russia Trump Russia Trump
Ukraine and Peach and Peach and Peach
lies lies lies stormy stormy [ __ ]
[ __ ] same garbage no evidence for
investigations no Trump Russia collusion
Adler should have the votes to do pretty
much whatever he wants in the house what
you're seeing are major political
ramifications believe it or not look at
this report from the examiner some
believe Nadler is even more on like a
both/and shift you got the shift show
and now you got the shift show with a
guy that's more hated than him and
president Trump already surging in the
polls support for impeachment is on a
steady rapid decline and sources now
telling Fox News that an impeachment
vote won't happen before Christmas
because of complex issues like Pelosi
doesn't have the votes
now Democrats are having a really hard
time staying focused look at this
Washington Post reporting some lawmakers
are trying to expand the impeachment
articles they even wanna revisit Russia
Russia Russia for investigation let's go
back to that one
they have lost touch with reality logic
reason common sense they've bifurcated
their brains we actually do have a quid
pro quo you're not getting the billion
dollars unless you fire the prosecutor
that I've been told is investigating my
zero experience son that Ukraine oil
companies paying millions there you go
but they have to shut that part of their
brain off just like they shut the part
of the brain off about the Hillary
bought and paid for
Russian dossier but the good news is and
this is the only good news and 336 days
you we the people of this country you
get to shock the world again we get to
read we get to do it one more time
2016 remember their faces President
Donald J Trump now president elect
imagine that CNN fake news ms @ DNC fake
news conspiracy theories we've now
project a Donald J Trump has been
reelected the 45th President United
States is that not worth the price of
admission that would be marvelous